[موسيقى]
انا لما مستش لما جينا هنا على الخيمه
قعدت معها 100 يوم من لما طلعنا من لما
طلعنا منغز لما هم استشهدت قعدت معها
ويعني عرفت كل شي اعملها يعني الحليب لما
تجوع اعرف لها انها ب بدها تاكل لما ب
تنام اعرفها انها بدها تاك بدها تنام يعني
وهي لما بدها تغير اعرفها انها بدها تغير
لما بدها تلبس اعرفها انها تلبس يعني
تعلمت لها كل شيء ق توليني وان وانا في
الحرب هذه لما لما سشد تمي في 100 يوم
هدول انا تعلمت كل شيء ل توليني ايش بدها
كيف بتعمل الرضعه الرضعه بعمل لها اياها
بسخن لها ميه كيف بتسخن الميه بجيب حطب
يعني بل بروح الم من الشارع حطب بعدين
بولعها وسخن لها عليها الميه بعد ما
اسخنها ل الميه بحط لها ع الرضعه قديش
الحليب بدها كم من سمتي ومعلقه حليب يا
معلقتين لما يكون في عندي وبدعها وهذا
[موسيقى]
وبطعم
g